de plus en plus de monde et c'est très
dense on n'arrête pas une fois que ça a
commencé et il faut recharger en
permanence donc on arrête pas
[Musique]
ce qu'on constate cette année c'est une
augmentation très importante du nombre
de personnes que nous accueillons
puisque à date par rapport à l'année
dernière on est à + 37%, je crois que la
moyenne à Paris est à 24 de mémoire et
en France on est un peu plus de 20 c'est
très important tout ça coupait avec
l'inflation il y a l'effet de cisaille
pour les restos qui font que c'est
difficile dans cette situation
[Musique]
avec l'inflation
tout est chamboulé on arrive plus à
manger normalement parfois on se prive
même parfois du repas de midi soit de
Jeanne le machin on arrive à déjeuner le
matin à midi non on attend le soir bon
les enfants
je peux dire j'essaye on peut pas dire
qu'il mange alors convenance donc on
essaye de gratter de
d'organisation en organisation pour
essayer de joindre les deux bouts
[Musique]
comme ça